nfc south are the tampa bay buccaneers
and hashtag tommy being over hyped as we
head into the season uh i think so i do
i think you know again
i i expect it to be an exciting football
team but like we're you know
we're talking like it's just a
guaranteed thing and i i don't look at
it that way and i know i'm probably in
the minority that what's a guaranteed
thing well
that they're definitely going to the
playoffs and they're going to definitely
be a super bowl contender and i just i
can't buy that yet i mean this is
football it's the ultimate team sport
man there's a lot of new things going on
there so i just look at that and go
i think we're just like
kind of swiping it to the side like you
know camaraderie playing together being
battle tested no problem they'll come
together twice in one day i got it i
know so i guess we're taking that for
granted a little bit and then of course
i do have questions about that defense
so
you know between all of those things and
of course they're in a pretty good
division to go along with it yeah i
certainly don't look at it as a slam
dunk that they're going to the playoffs
this year
yeah you actually to to get a little
yeah go ahead i'm looking i'm looking at
your seven teams and i don't see one
that begins with a b no so uh i'm
stunned by that all right look i don't
think they're overhyped because tom to
say they're over hyped is to say that
tom brady is overhyped tom brady is not
over hyped he's never been overhyped
he's always delivered he's driven he's
motivated from the day he's signed with
that team he's been working and focusing
and maybe fracturing a rule or two along
the way no harm no foul remember when he
showed up accidentally and brought at
byron left with his house to pick up the
playbook right when he also happened to
have a bag of footballs with him i just
carry a bag of footballs around because
you know you never know when you're
going to need a football like to maybe
go out and run some football plays in
the offensive coordinator's backyard
they it's throw caution to the wind
pandemic be damned rules be damned i'm
driven i'm motivated i'm focused to
prove
that i can win
without bill belichick
pushing my buttons and pulling my
strings and you know i don't know that
it's sustainable
but but in that first year after
i think there's enough that he carries
with him
that it works and and maybe it is
sustainable i mean when you think of the
difference between jameis winston and
tom brady all due respect to james
winston who's number three this year on
the new orleans saints depth chart he
threw 30 interceptions last year they
were still 7-7 through 14 games despite
jameis winston having one of the worst
seasons he could possibly have although
he had 30 touchdowns it's 30 touchdowns
and 30 interceptions they were seven and
seven you take him out of the mix and
you bring in one of the great
quarterbacks if not the greatest
quarterback of all time great leader six
super bowl rings too many to fit on one
hand and he brings that influence into
the locker room sure with a coach who's
smart enough to say while he holds uh
his rum and coke the drink that he
drinks when he isn't drinking go do it
yeah go have at it and just take over
and why not and i think it's gonna work
i think that tom brady has that aura
he's got the presence and he still has
the arm and you've said you said so no
doubt got the arm the arm's fine
no doubt gotta get rid of the football
while he still has time to do it before
he gets hit that's the key that's the
big question for me you know that's
that's what bothered me about last
year's play there there was too many
times where i saw man there's a guy open
20 yards down the field and he's already
let the ball go to get it out of his
hand because he doesn't want to take the
hit so yeah that scares me let alone
you know
yeah i offensive line questions a little
bit i'd like to see how that plays yeah
the formula of the new offense it's just
a little bit of an unproven commodity
and like you know you're right with what
you say about jameis winston yeah i get
it they were seven on seven but this is
one thing i think is being glossed over
in this conversation with going hey they
went they were seven and seven and you
know they went seven and nine with
jameis winston and 30 interceptions
jameis winston made a whole hell of a
lot more plays than tom brady did last
year so you're going to lose that i mean
if you took the highlight reel between
brady and winston last year in 2019 it's
not close jameis winston's highlight
reel will blow brady's out of the water
so you can't you got to forget you're
you might miss some of that too yeah
okay you might miss some of those
interceptions from jameis winston but
are you going to get all the 25 and 30
and 20 yard and the scrambling and great
plays jameis winston makes that way no
you're not so i guess i'm just saying i
just got to see it first i i can't stamp
it right now and that's that's that's
why i didn't pick them to go to the
playoffs won't be shocked like i get it
yeah i get it i understand that i just i
have and maybe i'm just being too caught
up in the narrative i i people say what
do you root for i root for a good story
and i think tom brady going to tampa and
the buccaneers turning it around after
all these years
of uh mediocrity really since 2008 is
that the last year they made it 2007.
2007 even worse so i just i just it's
one of those things where it's a fan
base that deserves to have a good team
definitely they've changed the uniforms
enough that i can actually look at the
game for more than three seconds now
it's like staring at a solar eclipse
with those awful numbers and jerseys
they had before and and you want to see
greatness continue i said after the
patriots won super bowl 51 coming back
from the 28-3 deficit against the
falcons we are now entering the
territory where tom brady is like
michael jordan in that you must be able
to say you saw him play live at some
point in your life that's where he
transcended too and here we are for four
seasons later so and unfortunately you
know not a lot of people are gonna get
to see him this year in person but he's
still got that aura and i think that's
gonna rub off on the teammates in the
same way that cam newton's presence is a
positive in the patriots locker room at
least the patriots players are used to
that the tampa bay players aren't right
right right and and i think it's going
to have a huge impact on that team so i
think i think the buccaneers win that
division who do you think wins it i'm
going to go with the saints the saints
to me just too talented no weakness to
their football team
great coaching staff uh
yeah i mean i think the saints are one
of the best teams in football the nfc
whatever you want to say i think they
will take the division
yeah and look i think that if it's not
the buccaneers it will be the saints and
they they get started on sunday right
out of the gates they did not hold back
what they could you know that's the
thing first week of the season they
could identify the 16 worst games of the
year and put them on all at once and
we'd still watch yeah we didn't do that
i gotta give the nfl credit for that
there are a bunch of great games this
weekend and saints hosting the
buccaneers is one of them you didn't hit
atlanta either because i see you got
atlanta going to the playoffs as well so
you got three in the south
bay i've got three well there's four
there's you could have up to four out of
a division now so i you've got three
wild card spots and we've been talking
about the falcons but when it came time
to put a name on it you wouldn't do it
no you you want to flirt with the
falcons but you don't want to date the
phone no i i can see what you see with
the falcons i i here's what it came down
to me with the the falcons i went the
last two years they've had the injury
bug and what i think in the year that we
don't have an off season they won't have
the injury bug it's a very thin football
team it is very top-heavy there has been
no depth there we've seen the last few
years two or three injuries to their
team and they almost fall apart so
i i just i don't i don't trust that
aspect of their team especially in a
year like this that was kind of my logic
but like if you made me pick a dark
horse super bowl team they would
probably be it like one of those teams
that's out of the top five or ten odds
in vegas he said who's a team that you
might throw some money on that might win
the super bowl and you're just taking a
shot on the atlanta falcons they're
they're starting 22 is a very impressive
group
but it also becomes difficult for you to
put them in your seven playoff teams
that just shows you you would consider
them a dark horse candidate to win the
super bowl but you can't put their name
down there's so many other good teams in
the nfc to choose from
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports